dans l'appartement de cette jeune
réfugié là où joue ses enfants coquerel
et souris y lisent régulièrement
domicile giron de l'immeuble assure
pourtant que des opérations
d'extermination se font toute l'année et
des problèmes auxquels ne s'habitue pas
les locataires de cet immeuble la salle
certains manifesté aujourd'hui à
l'initiative de syndicats de locataires
j'aimerais qu'on change au moins qu'on
s'occupe de tout ça pour qui un
changement pourquoi ne souffle pas dans
l'appartement
et puis à des moments aussi à des
infestations les cafards ou des punaises
de lit malgré que moi je prends des
produits on me connais toi y est mais de
temps en taille n 1 et le qatar n'ont
aucun contrôle sur le chauffage ils se
plaignent du froid qui rendraient leurs
appartements presque invivable parce que
c'est difficile de vivre dans une maison
comme si l'intérieur était à l'extérieur
la liste des départements
potentiellement et salubre et longue
puisqu'il y en aurait plus de 30000
inspectés rien qu'à montréal à montréal
un domaine sérieux coup de barre au
service de salubrité
donc dès les premiers budgets que notre
administration a présenté on a ajouté
des effectifs de budget de la capacité
d'agir et on voit déjà les résultats
à moins de 2' + qui étaient inspectés
avant par 4 à plusieurs propriétaires
choisissent malgré tout d'ignorer les
évident non conformité de la
municipalité
mais la ville pu prendre de grands
moyens on peut faire les travaux à un
lieu pour le propriétaire il est facturé
par la suite si on juge que c'est
nécessaire d'agir rapidement
on peut aussi appeler leurs créanciers
fait bouger avec d'autres moyens
80 ménages ont aussi été évacuées l'an
dernier à cause de l'insalubrité de
l'urologie la ville de montréal a
accéléré les inspections pour les
logements potentiellement et salubre
mais les sanctions demeurent rares pour
les propriétaires récalcitrants ici
michel marsolais radio canada montréal